on se croirait à la veille d'une guerre
à grande échelle
gloire à l'ukraine a déclaré le
président volodymyr zelensky en paradant
son artillerie dans l'est du pays
plus tôt il s'est même rendu dans les
tranchées pour encourager c'est trop et
les préparer aux pics
avec vous je suis conscient que nous
allons tous les bas une référence aux
dizaines de milliers de soldats russes
se déploie depuis des semaines aux
portes de l'ukraine et qui selon le
renseignement américain serait prête à
l'envahir à tout moment l'otan et ses
alliés préparent donc la réplique si
elle s'avère nécessaire et c'est le
président américain qui aujourd'hui sans
effet l'émissaire
joe biden et vladimir poutine ont
discuté pendant deux heures par
visioconférence
on aura vu que les politesses après quoi
il aurait prévenu chef du kremlin qu'une
évasion lui coûterait très cher comme
jamais auparavant
le kremlin n'a pour commenter une
entretien ce soir mais bien venir
poutine médecin depuis des semaines que
toute tentative d'expansion de l'otan en
ukraine sera considéré comme une menace
existentielle pour son peu
pour cet analyste il est clair que
vladimir poutine cherche encore à
négocier des garanties sur le plan
sécuritaire et veut le respect des
accords de minsk qui prévoit un statut
spécial pour les territoires occupés par
les séparatistes pro russes dans l'est
de l'ukraine
c'est aussi ce que pense la majorité des
gens que nous avons entendues dans la
ville frontalière de mario paul en
ukraine et mous dit nico il n'y aura pas
d' attaque d'hillary ça car la russie
n'en a pas besoin et l'ukraine encore
moins caniche nain mais on a peur de
cette jeune femme une solide et
pacifique et des victimes collatérales
d'un jeu politique
un jeu dangereux surtout car c'est la
deuxième fois cette année que la russie
utilise la menace d'une guerre pour
négocier avec l'occident dit cet
analyste
autrement dit le temps a intérêt à se
préparer pour toute éventualité et c'est
ce qu'elle fait et la maison blanche
confirme que parmi les sanctions
envisagées
suspendre le grand projet de pipeline
north stream 2 qui doit alimenter le gaz
naturel russe vers l'europe cette fois
fait partie des options il cite amaral
tresco radio-canada moscou